[Music]
hey the start of the summer anime season
is pretty soon I should probably get my
Austen's again and start watching some
of these shows in case I want to make a
video hey there are you an anime watcher
who's severely behind on seasonal anime
and have no idea what's even going on
well what a coincidence me too well what
a coincidence so what better way to
rectify that than with some first
impressions that you definitely won't
care about now that you'll definitely
care about now even though we do the
season let's start off with a
slice-of-life about centaurs so my
biggest problem nowadays we've seen
these monster girl shows is that I just
get too many unanswered questions about
the world of these monster girls how is
the center wearing trousers like how
does she actually put it on I can't see
how she would reach back there we'll
have the dexterity with her legs to do
so or is it even necessary would it be
public indecency if she didn't does this
answer the age-old question of how dogs
would wear trousers
why do mermaids have gaps so they could
wear bikinis did they evolve these gaps
just so they could wear bikinis is there
a mermaid based economy just for bikinis
see this is the problem these are the
questions that keep me up at night this
is this this is I'm sorry what are they
talking about
what a lot of people sent me this show
jokingly thinking I'd find some kind of
enjoyment out of its animes trash and so
am I am i right for her okay no just
stop I am offended if you think this
show is worth my time it is just bad may
I remind you that it is summer 2017 we
live in a post era Marga sensei world
the entire landscape of the trash genre
has changed and will never be the same
again and this show comes along with
this Tesco value prison school Carson
thinks it can stand toe to toe imitation
is the sincerest form of flattery but
when you are trying to match the Citizen
Kane of dick jokes I'll do the magnum
opus of garbage you better have
something special and miss [__]
Cindy's sunbed Sally and back pain Jane
are nothing even close to comparison so
you know what this is just bad just
scenes of tryhard pandering with
absolutely no innovation whatsoever I
mean really what reason could you give
me to watch a show like this why would I
go out my way to watch this alright
let's just move on for now what's what's
what's this all about
[__] man gamers is a show about gamers
actual real gamers like mobile gamers
but no it's actually legit because see
this is straight-up BlazBlue and see
this is straight-up not counter-strike
at least it better not be [__]
counter-strike because what the [__] is
this back alley method they're using to
play it it also bothers me a bit when I
see the main character because it's
almost as if the thought process for his
design with something along the lines of
okay how do we design the most bland
relatable protagonist possible with that
viewers can easily project themselves on
wait a minute speaking of games now I
didn't watch new game
[Music]
[Applause]
for the second season here is not called
new game - new game season T or anything
else it's just new game exclamation
point exclamation point why is this not
called new game + so it's a new fate and
these look like some sick-ass action
scene tell you this my eye should be
interesting let's see what this is all
about
oh okay so there are two Sabres I guess
oh I guess that's a master nope that's a
Marcin there note that's that a federal
Master swagger has 14 masters and
wearing okay so there's 14 masters and
14 servants so holy [__] that's like 28
characters and Joan of Arc and harmonic
you lion how am I supposed to keep up
with all these characters
alright well if there are too many
characters to pay attention to I guess
I'll just have to do the next best thing
and fine best girl and well saver of the
read and Joan of Arc just like an
inferior saber anyway but so I think
I've found a keeper guys
oh that's she that's like that's a guy
isn't it I'm just kidding it's 2017 and
of course it's acceptable to like
androgynous looking anime boys and I
think now is the perfect time to settle
that age-old debate of live traps the
gay or not because I have the definite
answer ah traps gay no traps are not gay
they're homosexual
[Music]
hey look it's free except less gay and
sets with guilty-looking dive animation
hey look it's URI oh nice except less
gay and it's set on land above GOG
looking necks hey Lucas URI oh nice
except there's no ice and it's just
straight-up URI
so far the show has achieved more hot
steamy relationship progression within
two minutes and most anime achieved
within 24 episodes I mean this chick
seems thirsty enough to drink the Amazon
River dry but what can I expect from a
show literally abbreviated to NTR let's
see there's two girls cheating on their
respective boyfriends with each other an
abusive jock and of course the good old
innocent Chuck Norris judging from the
first episode this has the potential to
end in schooldays level of relationship
[__] but I will say if the show
doesn't end in more scissoring and kill
the kill I will be very disappointed you
know what I'm going back to this welcome
to the ballroom isn't just URI on land
starring well-dressed giraffes it's a
genuinely instead and show but a boy
finding his true passion there's one of
my favorites of the season so far and I
highly recommend you give it a watch
because of Holly no one else is of
course it wouldn't be a proper anime
season without an e sake I share in it
see for those of you who don't know ye
say Kai means another world and has
become a genre I'm sure many of you are
aware of because we need about 10
million [__] new ones every season
now it used to be hey look it's just
another guy transported to a fancy word
but now they're just straight up putting
East Lee kind of title of these shows I
mean just look at mites and magic where
if you literally just cut out the first
two minutes of the show you'd have no
idea it was even a nice a Kai show why
is this an Issei guys show look I get it
the guy was a Gunpla nerd who was also a
programmer and that's why he's able to
design and program these otherworldly
robots so well but couldn't you have
just made a story about the character
being a super skilled engineers that are
being liked this guy can do anything
because no one here even knows how to
print f hello world and their primitive
technology still codes everything as
minions but I'm not done yet see it's a
guy transported to a fantasy world anime
but this time he has a smartphone Martha
is this really how much was great from
the barrel for ye sake I shows what
happened to a fancy anime that you know
were just fantasy anime
[Music]
the best first episode of this season
undoubtedly went to made in the best and
immediately grabbed my attention with
this amazing atmosphere and world
building there's an unbelievable sense
of adventure that instantly seizes your
curiosity not by explaining anything but
by dropping you knee-deep into this
world why are there chibi explorers
what's this massive worm monster flying
about that's not in CG why are there
robots in the world where are we even
what's that massive hole it gave me the
same feeling as when I first booted up
breath of the wild I wanted to find out
more and explore the world out of
genuine curiosity and just as that
curiosity is piqued you're giving your
first bit of exposition or dialogue at
the very end of the episode that just
leaves you wanting to explore more this
is how to start up a fancy world and I
can't tell you how big my boner was
during this opening sequence with the
fantastic visuals and brilliant insert
song and youfo table back at it again
with a beautiful-looking adaptation no
one gives a [__] about because the
source material isn't affiliated with
any types of moons hockey gear is a show
about gambling starring a bunch of
crazy-ass [__] chicks who get hot and
bothered when they're betting but as
cool as that is you know a wise man once
said long ago do not stick your dick in
crazy [__] that guy today I offer you
some new words of wisdom
you can't spell psychotic without hot
damn is this really worth my penis
honestly though what Walken yours with
an addictive gambling show where the
girls are really really really
enthusiastic about gambling like super
enthusiastic like extremely enthusiastic
like so enthusiastic I'm wet enough
sheesh of this girl I might hate not to
be that guy but I made the right [__]
call when I gave her a shout-out to the
manga a few months ago so if you do you
want to read ahead in the manga you can
do so at Boot Walker in the description
below and you can also use coupon code
gig out for five dollars off but you
know nothing I actually can't wait for
the most is that ova1 show where the
cars traveled to Vegas for a night that
we're totally gonna crowd fun into
production now for a hint I Haven
original Ajo girl is a tragic show but
I'm glad it exists there needs to be
more shows highlighting mental
disabilities and the struggles that
these people
go through from physical abuse
neglecting parents and arduous battles
with their addiction to bananas and it's
just tragic to see people looking at
this and just laughing oh okay
apologies apparently it's not about
mental disabilities it's just a guy who
really doesn't want to stick his dick in
stupid you know the seasons been a bit
quiet in the community with some of the
best shows being behind services I can't
get behind but at least we still got my
hero academia to keep us company and I
think this is a good time to bring this
up
look the tournament arkad my hero
academia was amazing but it's over now
I've made my whole video about it so I
think this is a good time to kill off
the toy demon Ark mean you know I love
my Toyman arks and will continue to love
my tournament ox we're constantly
shouting it out is getting tiring so
let's just move on now there's nothing
more to get excited about anymore way is
this a
hey guys hope you enjoyed that video
thank you very much this month to add
really on basil Leigh Watts Thrones melt
and everyone else a patron for
supporting this month and making this
video possible again if you do want to
read ahead in Calgary officially you can
do so the link to life the book Walker
and use coupon code gig up five dollars
off also I haven't officially announced
this on this channel yeah but I will be
guessing at control Expo in just under
two weeks in Santa Clara from August
25th to August 27th so if any of your
going I hope see you there once I get a
more detailed schedule what I'll be
doing I'll put out another video up
anyway that's it from me for now
I've been gigging and I'll see you all
next time